I'd like to talk about the risks of
taking
10 000 IUS of vitamin D3 sounds like a
lot ten thousand but is it really that
much just so you know very briefly I use
stand for international units okay so 10
000 international units of vitamin D is
equivalent to
not even one milligram not even a half a
milligram it's actually one quarter of
one milligram 0.25 milligrams which is
250 micrograms okay that's 10 000
international units of vitamin D3 so is
there a risk of taking that much I think
there's a bigger risk of not taking that
much let me explain I recently found
some information that literally blew me
away and I think it's going to blow you
away too but first let me just give you
a little Foundation of what we're
talking about the great majority of us
are deficient in vitamin D now I guess
the conflicting information is that the
rdas
of vitamin D
is between 600 to 800 international
units okay and now we're talking about
taking ten thousand it sounds like a
huge gap but what you have to realize is
that 600 to 800 IUS
is based on Old research relating to
preventing osteoporosis bone loss it's
not updated and correlated with all the
new information related to the benefit
of vitamin D for your immune system
what's even more wild is that vitamin D
is not really even a vitamin it's a
hormone and it acts very similar to
cortisol as an anti-inflammatory but
without the side effects every cell in
your body has receptors for vitamin D
the functions of vitamin D are very very
vast but I want this video to focus
mainly on why you need as a maintenance
dose 10 000 IUS it really has to do with
the barriers of absorption you have a
lot of things that are stopping vitamin
D from going into your body right you
have the sun like people don't get
enough sun or sun exposure to their skin
they don't go outside as much and if
they're going outside with a shirt on
and just getting exposure to their face
you're not going to even get close to
the amount that you need and also it's
almost impossible to get enough vitamin
D from the foods that we eat even if you
eat fatty fish and cod liver oil and egg
yolks which are higher in vitamin D3
you're still not going to reach the
levels that you need then you have
people that are overweight the more fat
right beneath your skin the harder it is
for the sun to penetrate to create the
vitamin D necessary then we have
metabolic syndrome okay if you have
diabetes or you have insulin resistance
vitamin D doesn't go in that well
um the older you are the skin becomes
thicker and it's harder to get your
vitamin D the more pigment you have in
other words the darker your skin the
less vitamin D absorption you're going
to have and also the more problem you
have with the gallbladder or the liver
let's say you have a fatty liver the
less absorption of vitamin D you're
going to have because you need bile to
help you absorb vitamin D from the food
as well as from a supplement because
it's a fat soluble vitamin and the more
kidney problems you have the less
vitamin D you're going to have as well
so the way it works is you have these
precursor or inactive
vitamin D compounds that have to be
converted to the active form of vitamin
D and they go through various steps but
there's a two primary steps one through
the liver and one through the kidney to
eventually get this active form of
vitamin D3 it then has to be absorbed in
your receptors and those receptors are
called vitamin D receptors and if you
have an infection like a viral infection
these these viruses can trick your body
by downgrading The receptors and
preventing you from absorbing vitamin D3
so that's another barrier if your immune
compromised or you have an immune system
problem the amount of vitamin D you're
going to need is going to have to be a
lot more to penetrate that resistance
that the virus has strategically created
for you and when they do a blood test
for vitamin D they're not testing the
active form of vitamin D they're testing
the inactive form and the reason why is
because if they tested the active form
there's a lot of problems with that
number one being that it has a very
short half-life like I think it's uh
four to six hours compared to two to
three weeks for the inactive
vitamin D3 and also the active form of
vitamin D3 is a thousand times less than
the inactive so apparently I have a lot
of inactive vitamin D sitting there
waiting to be converted and also when
you're deficient in the inactive version
of vitamin D3
your body will then compensate and make
more of the active vitamin D3 so if you
tested the active vitamin D3 and it
shows up normal it doesn't really give
you a lot of information so this is why
the inactive form is tested but this
next thing is going to blow you away
okay and this relates to your genes
I've been recently involved in a lot of
research in genetics looking at um
what's called polymorphisms which are
alterations in certain genes that make
you more susceptible to having problems
with certain illnesses but there's three
polymorphisms that are routinely tested
when you do your DNA test that I need to
talk about because in the last I would
say several months I tested their DNA
they're mainly friends and family
members and I wanted to just get
experience in this topic and testing
real people is a very good way to do
that and check this out this is just
related to vitamin D out of the 21
people that I tested 100 of them had at
least one problem with vitamin D
absorption in other words they had at
least one genetic issue with their
vitamin D which is another barrier that
I don't think is really acknowledged or
even knowned it could be the next 21
people I test
don't have a problem with vitamin D but
with this small sample there was 21 out
of 20 when people had a problem relating
to vitamin D genes in the first Gene it
was called the cyp
2r1 and out of all the 21 people tested
90 of them had a problem with this Gene
and 38 of that group had a major problem
with that polymorphism or mutation and
this Gene is one of the two steps in the
conversion from the inactive to the
active and occurs in the liver so in
other words if you have a problem with
this Gene you're going to have a problem
in converting the inactive form to the
active form now let's talk about the
other two genes these other two genes
were involved with Transportation like
binding to a protein and transporting
this vitamin D throughout your
circulation and out of all 21
and the first transporter gene there was
like 61 percent of the people that had a
problem with that one and then with that
second transporter there was like 76 of
the people that had a problem with that
Gene so a lot of people didn't have a
problem just with one gene it was all
three genes so if we take this genetic
alteration on top of all these other
barriers now we can see ten thousand IUS
is not going to be toxic at all in fact
it's going to be necessary to penetrate
some of these big barriers that people
are up against that being said how much
vitamin D does create a toxicity effect
well that's still in debate but based on
all the research that I looked at it
would take hundreds of thousands of
international units of vitamin D for
months before it created a Toxic effect
and that Toxic effect is primarily
hypercalcemia and the risk of that
problem is mainly kidney stones so just
as a precautionary step if you're
drinking uh two and a half liters of
fluid a day that decreases your risk big
time of getting a kidney stone because
you're going to keep the urine diluted
and then on top of that if you take some
of the supporting nutrients that allows
vitamin D absorption as well as the
function of it and also factors that
protect you against hypercalcemia like
vitamin K2
magnesium B6 zinc then that puts you
even in a safer range and one last point
about getting your blood tested with
vitamin D
to date there's still no consensus from
the entire medical community on what
those values should be but most doctors
is between 150 to 200 nanograms per
milliliter but again when they do a
blood test they're looking at the
inactive vitamin D they're not looking
at the Active vitamin D and they're also
not looking at what happens in the
vitamin D receptor absorption into your
cells we're not looking at that level if
you also have a genetic problem in the
vitamin D receptor or you have an
infection or some virus that's
downgrading that vitamin D receptor or
even you have an autoimmune disease that
has this downgraded vitamin D receptor
you might need much much higher levels
of vitamin D3 than 10 000 IUS now I
created another really interesting video
on the toxicity effect and I looked at
more of the percentages based on all the
research out there of what could happen
What Kofi you need to take if you
haven't seen this video you should check
it out it's really interesting